hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 11 recap and
review it was titled 411 exit exit with
all lowercase letters except the capital
X and was written and directed by series
creator Sam s mail this video will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in the mr. robot series up to
episode 11 of season 4 so if you haven't
watched it this video is not for you
just please come back after you watch
the episode and watch my recap it's an
exciting time in the world this is my
favorite moment in this episode and it
answers the age-old question what would
you say if you found yourself trapped in
a room in a nuclear power plant with an
alternate personality you created to
protect yourself as the world is coming
to an end it's an exciting time in the
world and it is an exciting time to be a
mr. robot fan we are at the end of the
road next week there's a two-hour series
finale and we're gonna find out how the
whole thing ends personally I think it's
a lot of fun that I don't know what's
going to happen in those two hours I
know what I just saw I've watched
episode 11 twice now paying close
attention to everything that went down
I'm a huge fan I've been immersed in the
mr. robot world for over four years at
this point and I really have no idea how
it's all going to end I'll talk more
about that after I go through the recap
let's talk about everything that
happened in the episode and then we'll
talk some more about the ending the
episode opens directly from the
previously on and we catch up with
whiterose when we last saw her getting
ready in that apartment in New York this
wasn't a big surprise if you watched the
trailers closely but we see the scene
where she comes down the stairs and all
of the FBI agents of the SWAT team that
went to her place are slaughtered dead
bodies all over the place she stops at
one who's still alive and says you were
looking for Minister Zhang he's not here
there's only white rose and from that
moment we realized we are officially in
the endgame from there we rewind the
clock a little bit to visit Darlene and
Elliot saying goodbye at the motel
parking lot we saw this in episode 10
this time we see the whole conversation
and we see Elliot say to Darlene thank
you for never giving up on him
there's a really strange bit here when
Darlene's leaving because she speaks
directly to mr. robot but we don't have
time to dwell on that because mr. robot
and Elliot start to get into an argument
mr. robot believes it's a mistake to go
after white roses machine
he tells Elliot that they completed
their goal if he wants to do this
he'll essentially be fighting an endless
war there always be something else
that's gonna come up if he doesn't stop
now Elliot isn't deterred as far as he's
concerned everything started there and
white rose isn't dead until her machine
is dead so he heads off on his own to
where it all began
that would be Washington Township New
Jersey he takes a bus and then a long
walk through the town and things are
bizarre as soon as he shows up nobody
seems to be Manning the gate there's a
couple cars and trucks racing away from
the scene later we learned that white
rose and her minions have showed up and
killed everybody but before we learned
that we watched as Elliot installs his
malware that goes off without a problem
he has a moment of satisfaction and
relief and then things change
considerably and we get the first of
many fan surprises as we get to the end
of the story hamburger man which is a
recurring character we've seen several
times throughout the series shows up and
he actually speaks so that was fun he's
with a group of foot soldiers who are
all wearing dark army masks and they
take Elliot on a tour through the
building to meet with White Rose where
we see that there are dead bodies
everywhere on the way we see portraits
of physicists on the walls their faces
have been painted over white red and
black seems to be the colors that were
used Anneli it ends up in a room that is
reminiscent of where we saw Angela meet
with White Rose in the past this room is
set up and decorated to cater to Elliot
rather than Angela and this is where
Elliot and White Rose finally have their
conversation about her plans things
start off with Elliot saying that he
won't be brainwashed that this will not
work on him like it worked on Angela BD
Wong does a fantastic job here this is a
great bit of acting White Rose
challenges Eliot's worldview essentially
saying that they have the same goals
Eliot rejects this and most importantly
I think Elliot says that
he hates society that's true but he
still believes in people some of them
continues to love him even when he tries
to get rid of them and all of that helps
him heal then things go off the rails
it's presented as a choice white road
says that Elliot gets to decide right
before she shoots herself in the head
it was pretty shocking in the lead-up to
the suicide the alarms had started to
sound the tension was coming from the
fact that white rose had turned the
machine on the mysterious machine the
one that's been in the background of
this entire series she's turned it on
and it's draining power from the cooling
system of the reactor so the whole thing
is gonna melt down she is unaffected by
this this does not matter as far as
she's concerned and of course she takes
her own life to put an exclamation point
at the end of that sentence
this leaves Elliot in the room to try to
figure out what to do mr. robot shows up
gets him to check the phone they find
out the code to the door is five nine
zero five zero nine like the five nine
hack before they can leave though Elliot
finds a disk labeled exit which was the
title of the episode it's in the copy of
resurrection which was left next to the
Apple 2e on the desk he loads the game
up and the first time he plays it he
does it wrong he leaves his friend
behind the alarms don't stop and he
decides to try it again this time he
stays but by now it's too late he
settles down in the chair says I love
you too mr. robot with white roses dead
body on the floor and as far as we can
tell that's that the destruction is
complete the screen fades to red and
then we wake up in a brand new place it
is Elliot's apartment in New York but
it's completely different and the person
that looks like Elliot that lives inside
of it is different as well he wakes up
and puts on records he gets ready he
uses products and he talks to Angela his
fiancee on the computer so we're not in
the same New York that we spent time in
for the last four seasons and we're not
with the same Elliot that we've come to
know this Elliot is a CEO he's confident
he wears white shoes and sweaters he's
getting ready to get married he's an
only child and his father is still in
his life he's not dead and he doesn't
seem like the kind of guy that would
sexually abuse his son
in this world Ecore is actually named F
Corp and that's where we see our first
glitch we also see that there is a
earthquake which is centered at
Washington Township we see that white
rose exists in this world but she is a
rich philanthropist who's out there
doing good in the world and when Elliott
goes to work we see he's pitching all
save for the F Corp account his meetings
with Tyrell and this Tyrell is much
different as well he's essentially the
opposite of the Tyrell from our story
and we really don't know what's going on
we got a different world where all the
people who are dead are alive all the
bad things that happened Elliott
probably didn't happen
Darlene doesn't exist or at least not as
his sister and you could say that this
is an improvement over the life that
Elliott had in our world all of this is
thrown in question though in the closing
scene of the episode where he comes home
and I mean he as in white shoes sweater
Elliott CEO Elliott comes home to find
himself black hoodie wearing normal
Elliott in his room so the first time I
watched this I thought that this was
literally Elliott in a different life
like whatever happened he was zapped
into a life on the second watch it
seemed a lot more likely to me that
Elliott was zapped into this world and
he's the one that shows up at the end to
meet an alternate version of himself
what's happening I can't say for sure
but what I can say and what I feel
pretty strongly about is that the series
will not end with Elliott becoming the
guy with the white shoes and the sweater
will he have a choice to make will he
have a choice to choose to be in that
world or be in the other world I don't
know is this world real is it really
happening I mean everything that
happened after he goes to Washington
Township was suspect it doesn't mean it
didn't happen but there's definitely a
chance that it didn't how that might
play out is anyone's guess and there are
tons of guesses about it what seems
certain to me is that the last two hours
are going to be about him trying to
figure out what's going on there are so
many directions this could go there are
so many different things that could be
happening here I find it awesome I find
it fantastic depending on which theories
you like you may feel like that they
have been confirmed that you're seeing
it play out just like you
thought you would but for me I'm just
enjoying the turn that it took I mean
it's just not what I expected to happen
but I'm right here for it I cannot wait
to see what happens and I have full
faith that it's gonna be an awesome
two-hour ride this is a show that has
been built on the unreliable narrator
Elliot who hasn't talked to us this
entire season mr. robot has stepped up
to do that a little but I feel like we
need to be able to question everything
in season two Elliot was in jail and he
kept that from us it's well established
that we can't trust everything that we
see Elliot's relationship with reality
is not the same as ours so is it really
happening I'm torn I mean could White
Rose have been pushed to activate this
plan because of the hack the destruction
of the Deus group basically the daxing
possibly if that's the case though like
why was the Congo so important why do we
have that whole storyline if she just
needed something to push her over the
edge to do it right there in New Jersey
do I like the alternatives like Elliot
being asleep or being in a coma or this
all being a dream of some sort not
particularly but it's also very possible
that it all could be inside Elliot's
head we've seen evidence of this in the
past and we've seen the boardroom we
know that some of the things that we've
seen have not existed in reality my
least favorite theories are the
simulation theories I know there's
evidence out there like the 11:16 time
that we keep seeing over and over again
and I get the idea behind the Alderson
loop theory I mean these are popular
theories so no offense if you like those
it's just that I think we had a
fantastic four seasons of TV where we
learned about Elliot's mental state and
the trauma and his isolation and
loneliness in my mind I don't connect
the dots that all it's all gonna end in
a simulation doesn't mean it couldn't
work I wasn't a big fan of the prison
theory I remember seeing it today it
came out right after season 2 episode 1
aired someone guessed it right off the
bat I read it I liked it then I didn't
like it because I didn't want the show
to be filled with twists and turns all
the time that turned out fine whenever
it was revealed I liked it and I was all
for it so I don't like the alternatives
but I don't necessarily want to see
alternate realities be true either
alternate universes how would this have
worked when she showed her presentation
to Angela I mean she shoots herself in
the head here if this is real if this is
happening whiterose as we know her is
dead
that didn't happen whenever this
presentation happened with Angela we see
Angela in Elliot's visions here but how
is any of that connected did I like to
see the old characters brought back all
the Lloyd Tyrell of course I did I
really did and I think what stands out
to me the most about those sequences is
not I know a lot of people are thinking
that Tyrells in on it and there's this
thing going on there that didn't jump
out at me at all what did jump out at me
was Edward's phone and Angela's mom
answering the phone but not speaking on
the other line there's also the blood in
the garbage can and Elliot didn't have
his wallet that all hints to me that our
Elliot the one we've been following all
this time is probably involved with some
of those things that we see happening
the telephone is the easiest one he went
to the mr. robot shop
Eduard left his phone out on the display
case or whatever Elliot picks it up he
sees the picture of the family without
Darlene freaks out and leaves I think
those are the parts that I found
interesting about this as I said they
really set up this idea of the third and
they really laid it out there that
Darlene might be the key to that her
seeing mr. robot in this episode was
definitely bizarre and I don't really
know what to make of that
magda and young Elliot showed up just
after that in one way or another we're
all going back into that boardroom like
that has to happen before the series
ends wherever we're at now however we're
at now there has to be a bridge to that
part of the story so I am gonna leave
the video there I'm super excited for
this finale I'm super excited that I
don't know what's gonna happen and I'm
really interested to hear what you guys
think in the